ALEX LEVICH: Hi, everyone.
This is Alex Levich.
This is Women Techmakers Product
Management with Alex Levich.
I'm product manager at
Google, and today we'll
be talking about
creativity and innovation.
This is our guest,
Shimrit Ben-Yair
who is a product manager
for YouTube Kids.
Welcome, Shimrit.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR:
Thank you, Alex.
Thanks for having me.
ALEX LEVICH: It's our pleasure.
Shimrit, why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: Sure.
I'm a product
manager at YouTube.
I recently launched
our kids product.
And I've been at Google
for almost six years now.
So before that, I worked
on Google+, on social.
And before that, I worked on
Google Groups and Google Docs.
Outside of work, I'm a mom.
I have two kids,
which may or may not
have inspired my
work on YouTube Kids.
And I'm really excited
to be with you, today.
ALEX LEVICH: Wonderful.
Thank you.
So Shimrit, tell us about
creativity and innovation.
How important is that in
a product manager role?
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: I think
creativity and innovation
is a central quality
in a product manager.
But I think, people
often think of creativity
as sort of coming up
with a brand new idea.
All of a sudden, you have this
completely different idea.
And it's like this magical idea,
and everyone should go do it.
I think that happens.
But I think often
creativity is actually
just looking at the world
with a fresh set of eyes
every single day.
So yes, it's about looking at
products in a different way.
But it's also about looking
at people in a different way.
Understanding--
ALEX LEVICH: Our
users, for example.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: Our users,
for one-- understanding,
empathizing with them
in different ways,
what's working for them,
what's not working for them.
The people we work with, right?
It's understanding,
oh, you know,
is this idea that
I'm rejecting--
why am I rejecting it?
Is it because I just don't see
the world like he or she does,
or is it because
there's something
really wrong with this idea?
So I think creativity is
really about understanding,
recognizing our
biases, recognizing
that everyone's
looking at the world
from a very narrow place, right?
And seeing, well, can we tackle
things in a different way?
Can we improve things
in a meaningful way?
ALEX LEVICH: That is so true.
This reminds me of Chrome OS.
So Chrome OS is a laptop, right?
So the idea existed for
a while, as we know.
But the idea of creating a
laptop at $200 that's still
very high quality
and people can use,
that's a very interesting idea
that did not exist before.
And we developed in
a different manner,
and we are scaling in
a different manner.
And people are enjoying
Chromebooks all over the world.
I completely agree with you.
But tell me this, how
do you push yourself
in a situation where you can
look with a fresh pair of eyes.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: I think that
there are a few ways to do it.
So I think that
creativity-- by the way,
I find that
creativity is actually
a skill that's learned.
It's like a muscle
that's trained.
It's not like, oh, I was either
born with that or I wasn't.
It's not a binary thing.
I think everyone can
grow it and cultivate it.
First and foremost, it's
surrounding yourself
with people who you
can be creative with.
For product manager, it's
your engineering leads
and understanding how to parse
their ideas, parse their input.
It's your designers
and understanding
how they're seeing
the world, what
ideas they're coming up with.
Its marketing,
who's very in touch
with users and their needs.
So it's creating
that environment
in which you're
interacting with a lot
of different kinds of people.
A diverse environment is
really important, I find,
for creativity.
Another really important
aspect is finding inspiration.
In order for you to
create space to think
of the world in a new way, you
have to have time, down time,
for this inspiration.
For me, I get a lot
of my inspiration
from museums, and art
museums, and contemporary art
that have nothing to
do with technology--
rarely have anything
to do with technology,
but I see them as
like these quizzes
or like these question marks of
like, hm, what does this mean.
Or, this even just
makes me feel good.
So that inspires me so.
Art is one thing, I think.
Social time is really important.
ALEX LEVICH: Yeah.
Just talking to people and your
friends who use your products.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: Exactly.
ALEX LEVICH: Or even your kids.
I always get lots of
inspiration and ideas from kids
and how they approach things
they've never seen before.
I bet you've seen this with your
kids and the YouTube kids app
actually.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: Yeah.
I saw it with my own kids.
And I saw it with
all the kids that we
were testing the product with.
When we built the app,
we thought, oh, we
want to build a family
friendly version of YouTube.
Easy peasy.
We as parents--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MERIT BEN-YAIR: Yeah.
We as parents know how our
kids are using the app.
But actually, it turns out to
be a much more nuanced thing.
As our testers, as my kids
and other kids of Googlers
and YouTubers were
using the app,
you see, actually, fingers
are clumsier than we thought.
They're using the border
of the screen, what
we call the chrome of the
screen in a different way
than what we expect.
So we had to make
tap targets bigger.
Kids don't read.
So even the text that
we were emphasizing
was useless to younger kids.
So we had to make
images be bigger.
Another thing is
actually borrowing
from the world of video games.
So kids today play a lot
of games all the time.
And they're expecting
iconography that's playful.
They're expecting animations.
They're expecting sounds.
So we added those in
so that it would really
represent kind of what the
world looks like for kids,
and bring that into YouTube.
ALEX LEVICH: That
sounds very right.
I totally see it
in the app today.
My kids love using it.
Every day, I give it to them.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: That's good.
Continue.
ALEX LEVICH: We will.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: OK, good.
ALEX LEVICH: As a
Chromecast integration.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: OK.
Sounds good.
We're working on it.
ALEX LEVICH: This is
all very important.
But sometimes there are
challenging moments.
Not always will you have your
eureka moment when you need it.
And you're trying to solve
problems everyday at work.
How have you dealt
with it in the past?
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR:
Creativity is actually
really weaved in
and tied in strongly
to communication and analysis.
One of the things that I think
people who are not creative do
is they just want to
rush to a solution.
They're confronted with a
problem, and they're like,
OK, I'm going to spend a little
bit of time finding out--
and then they're
like, OK, we're going
to do this and this and this.
But actually, the best product
managers and the best leaders
that I see are
able to really take
time to think and understand
the problem, and say, OK, well
what is the real issue here.
Pause.
And say, OK, these
are the dimensions
that we're dealing with.
This is the issue.
There's something
that we're missing.
They're able to bring in
different types of people
for their input and
analyze tradeoffs
before they jump to a solution.
So to me, creativity
is actually tied
into dealing with ambiguity.
And the best PMs that
I know are able to deal
with a high level of ambiguity.
You're able to
say, actually, I'm
going to create an
environment that's
a little bit more ambiguous
for the time being
until we find the
right solution.
And they're able to shield
all the fear, uncertainty,
and doubt that
results from-- no one
likes an ambiguous situation.
Oh, what do you mean we have
this problem in the product
that we don't know how to fix?
They're saying, yeah, and
we're going to, by Thursday,
or Friday, or next week, we're
going to have a solution.
But we're pausing to
really understand it.
And I think that discipline
is really important.
ALEX LEVICH: Yeah.
I've seen it many times in
our work here at Google.
And it is very tough,
but must be done,
and definitely gets us
to better solutions.
Completely agree.
You mentioned downtime before,
and it also kinds of leads
into your strengths
and your ability
to deal with ambiguity and
not rushing into solutions.
How do you balance
work and life?
How do you find time
to go to museums,
take care of two young kids, and
deal with ambiguity every day
at work?
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: When I
became a parent four years ago,
I realized that I would never,
ever be able to compete again
on my time spent at the office.
If I wanted to have a meaningful
experience as a parent
and have time with
my kids, that means
that I would need to have
a pretty predictable time
in which I come to work.
The time that I
became a parent has
made me a much better product
manager, in my opinion.
I'm a much better
leader because now I
know that every day, at the
same time-- for me at 5:30--
I go home and I spend
time with my kids.
And so I have to be much
more organized about my day.
I have to be much more
thoughtful about the things
that I do and not do.
And I think that that actually
creates a better environment
for the people around me and
for the product because we're
able to focus and
do fewer things,
but do them really, really well.
ALEX LEVICH:
Prioritize and focus.
Exactly.
I feel the same way.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: I also
feel like as a working mom,
a lot of the pressures that
working moms have is actually
self-inflicted.
It's like, oh, I'm feeling
guilty I'm at work.
Oh, why am I not with my kids?
Oh, I'm with my kids-- oh,
why am I not checking email
or why am I not at work?
And I think that actually--
ALEX LEVICH: It's
important to separate.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: It's
important to recognize this.
I think somehow, maybe
culturally, in like the past 50
years or I don't know what it
is that has wired us to look
at the world with
this guilt mindset,
but really I try to just be
present when I'm with my kids.
I try not to be on email.
I failed occasionally,
but most of the time,
I try to be with my kids.
And when I'm at work, I
don't linger and think, oh,
I wish I could be
with a park now.
And I think that
that has liberated
me to be able to focus and to
be able to have a good time.
I think creativity
and innovation--
to tie back into your
original question--
is all about creating space.
If you're constantly
just transactional,
you're never going
to have space to look
at the world with
a fresh set of eyes
and to do things
in a better way.
ALEX LEVICH: So if creativity
is this muscle that you train,
is it important to
find roles where
you would be more in a
position to train it everyday?
Or what's a good role
to take in your mind?
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR:
Every role is going
to have some degree
of creativity.
Products have different
levels of maturity.
And actually, I've been
fortunate in my career
to have worked on products with
different levels of maturity.
When I first joined Google,
I worked on Google Groups
and Google Docs.
And they were already
launched products.
And there, I was just
making improvements to them.
So there, I had to be creative
in improving an existing
product that already
had a set of users
with very specific needs.
But still, I needed to
understand, OK, well,
how do we do well for-- how do
we understand our user base?
How do we make sure
everyone's happy?
That was a very
different problem
than when I'm working
on YouTube Kids.
That was a brand new product
experience that we launched.
The first time that YouTube
launches a product that's
friendly for families.
So expectations are
a little different.
So I personally
think you're going
to have creativity in every
single role that you have.
But it's just the creativity
is going to manifest itself
in different ways.
When choosing roles and when
choosing things to focus on,
I think the three
most important things
are to choose an area that has
a lot of growth ahead of it,
to choose an area
in which you feel
like, OK, I'm learning a skill
that I didn't in the past.
I don't know
monetization, so I'm
going to choose a role
that has a lot of ads,
or something, a subscription
that I can work on.
Or I don't know mobile well, so
I'm going to work on Android,
or I'm going to work
on a mobile app.
So I think that's
a second element.
And then third, and most
important in my opinion,
is choosing a product
that you're just
going to love working
with the people.
Because with the right people,
you can build any product.
ALEX LEVICH: Yeah.
Goes back to the partnerships
that you mentioned.
You're able to forms those and
be creative and innovative.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR: Exactly.
ALEX LEVICH: That
makes perfect sense.
Well, Shimrit, thank you so
much for being here with us
and sharing your insight.
SHIMRIT BEN-YAIR:
Oh, you're welcome.
Thanks for having me.
ALEX LEVICH: And thanks
everyone for watching.
This is Product Management
with Alex Levich.
Stay tuned for upcoming
episodes of Women
Techmakers, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel.